well you guys there's so much to enjoy
here at the magical forest right now I'm
one of I'm one of the many rides they
have here but there's also games and
food and I hear lots of candy kiddos and
I'm joined by Opportunity Village
Community engagement director Heather
Davis again this all benefits such a
great cause tell us what people can
enjoy here though for the price starting
at 22 Yeah we have carnival games and
rides we have mini golf we have uh
trick-or-treating stations all the
carnival food you would want to enjoy
and just a lot of fun photo apps just a
fun time for people to come out and
enjoy the season awesome awesome and I
know that you guys also have a little
bit of a scarier option not as Kitty
family friendly as well also benefiting
Opportunity Village that's amazing yes
Vegas Fright Nights it's a separate
ticket and it's 300 houses for the one
ticket price now for folks who don't
know about Opportunity Village they've
been in the community for a long time
volunteering helping giving back this is
really one of those local Vegas
non-profits everybody loves tell us a
little bit more about them and how this
fun event benefits you at yeah well we
will start it in 1954 by seven families
who were looking for something for their
children who had disabilities and today
that has grown into serving over 3 000
individuals and the families who love
them awesome thank you so much Heather
for chatting with us today it's
definitely like I said so much to do
here at Halloween as well as at the
Vegas Fright Nights all right here at
magical forest and of course you can
enjoy all of this every day including
Halloween from 5 30 to 9. tickets are
also going to be on our website all
those details and more on 8newsnow.com
for now live from natural force I'm
Candace Charles a news now